Hey guys Dr.Berg sure we're going to
talk about the biggest mistake people
make doing the ketosis diet
ok basically consuming too much fat if
you look up the ketosis diet they say
that you can have eighty-five percent of
your calories of fat right that is a lot
of fat if you were to consume 2,500
calories from fat that comes out to 220
grams of fat that is way too much so
what will happen is you're going to
burning and that fat and that's happened
into your own fat you'll be in ketosis
but you won't lose anyway
ok so i suggest you reduce it down to
about 60 from the calories but it's kind
of like you have to go slow with the fat
the fat is the big variable that you
want to kind of gradually increase
because a lot of people can't digest
that you have to get used to you have to
build up your enzymes so this whole idea
of like just dumping all this butter or
coconut oil in your coffee and just
start plugging all these kiddo bombs
into the the meals not actually a good
thing
well if it for some people they can do
it other people they can so ketosis and
general suppresses your appetite so
what's gonna happen is you're going to
get your not going to be hungry
hardly at all anymore you're gonna be
able to go many many hours without
eating
so you want to let let the hunger
dictate how much fat you eat after you
get in ketosis you can back off some of
the fat and not have so much and then
you can actually start living off your
own reserves your own fat in your belly
and the rest of the body but there are
people that just overdo it especially
like the keto bombshell ditzy the whole
plate and I actually have a lot of
videos and how to make them so the whole
goal was just have like one
ok but I would just if you're not hungry
cut down the fat and go a little bit
lighter it's really each meal you have
to judge how much you need you might be
a little bit more but don't go crazy
okay because that's going to slow you
down
alright thanks for watching
guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and i
will see you in the next video